with a backlash against California
sanctuary state law now includes a city
in LA County that's big early this
morning the Santa Clarita City Council
voted unanimously 5 to 0 to oppose the
law and to file a brief supporting the
Trump administration's lawsuit against
California joining us now the
councilmember who first raised the issue
bob Keller Bob hats off to you in Santa
Clarita you voted to try to take back
the power away from the unaccountable
it's seeming seemingly unaccountable
elites in your state things got pretty
heated there I want to play a montage of
some of the sound from the hearing last
night let's watch you are hearing the
voices of patriotic people that love
their country California has gone from
the Golden State into a state of
lawlessness we're not talking about
immigration we're talking about
criminality we are tired we are fed up
by the lawlessness of the Democratic
Party sanctuary cities are magnets for
criminal aliens on the right way you are
not entitled to be here respect
Americans this is America were there
counter protests Bob yes there was Laura
and by the way thank you so much for
having me on your program it's a real
honor last night that was a record book
last night here for Santa Clarita and if
you can tell we were in the council
chamber on this program but we had to
turn out that was absolutely
unbelievable when it was all said and
done I would say that the audience was
probably around either 9 or 10 to 1 and
meaning that the the mass majority of
the people here in attendance were
absolutely here to stand up for America
the principles of this country and to
oppose SB 54 that is absolutely just
there's been the issue that's gone over
the top here in the state of California
and certainly here and in my city of
Santa Clarita Bob I think the president
should make a lot more trips to
California there's the list of all the
California counties that are
using the sanctuary policies it's
growing I think you should make more
trips to California go to places like
Santa Clarita talk to the people in
places where people don't agree with
them on everything and hit this theme do
you agree that this could be a turning
point for the beginning of a possible
crack of the Democrats stronghold in
California you know I absolutely believe
that Laurel I and I will tell you and
this didn't come from anything other
than the people here last night in
attendance so many of them were wearing
their make America great again red hats
so many of them said god bless President
Trump and and you could just feel they
pent-up frustration from all of the
folks that were here last night they
wanted to and I made this comment just
before we ultimately made a motion and a
vote on this matter which was almost
1:30 in the morning but that the people
that were here you could tell that they
wanted to finally get it off their chest
and be heard on the matters and the
frustrations of the issues that are
going on in the state of California yeah
I do not think California's lost to the
Republican Party I think Trump needs to
go there and go off and Bob Keller great
news coming out of your County last
night in LA County needs it badly so
thank you so much